hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday February 15th 2016 hello how are
you how was your world going on this
Monday how was your Valentine's Day huh
did you get her something special if
you're a smart son of a [ __ ] you're
either not in a relationship or you're
not taking her out until tonight or
tomorrow whatever whenever the prices go
back down again you know and by the way
if enough people start doing this and
the old [ __ ] restaurants get wise to
it and they start making their prices
higher Valentine's Day prices a few days
before a few days after then [ __ ]
wait a week wait a month do it a month
earlier
it's the biggest [ __ ] ripoff probably
of the year other than probably what's
going on to Bernie Sanders but I don't
really understand I guess she has some
super-delegates you know oh [ __ ]
Hillary Clinton's got the super dejes
the super-delegates she already yeah
it's a hundred she only needs a hundred
twenty whatever the [ __ ] that is Jesus
Christ it's like it's like playing
bridge trying to keep up what's going on
I have no idea all I know is I like that
Bernie looks like an old dog trying to
eat a meal when he's talking however the
[ __ ] jowls going and the weird thing
said his fingers do I like it I could
look at that for four years I got to
admit that as much as I don't like all
the racist [ __ ] Trump is doing I do love
some [ __ ] jerk-off yelling at other
politicians so that part has been
enjoyable you're a liar there weren't
any match weapons of mass destruction
and they know it many sounds like he's
quoting some podcasts I have no idea
some point I'm gonna start paying
attention there's got to be some
even-keeled so-and-so out there I have
no [ __ ] clue I have no clue and last
week I said that I hate it when people
in the public eye talk about politics
you know that's not true I hate when
they [ __ ] tell me why I should vote
for somebody
oh [ __ ] will you we you the guy from
interview with the vampire oh yeah
who should I elect for leader of the
free world it was like when Tom Cruise
was talking about psychology it's like
oh yeah you pretended to be a Shogun
warrior Ana NASCAR champion let me wipe
but by all means let me listen to you
talk about modern medicine as long as
you preface it with like I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't know what I'm talking
about but I hear you go you know but
when you really start believing it
that's when you get in trouble maybe I
believe it maybe this is the way I'm
just sort of soft-pedaling it to you I'm
playing the [ __ ] is I'm [ __ ] feeding
you might look putting a little ringworm
in your [ __ ] here whatever people say
there with the [ __ ] ear worm write
some song you can't stand gets in your
[ __ ] head you know it's kind of a
weird one is what a song you like gets
in your head and then you don't mind and
then you drive everybody nuts around you
like Steve Gorman from Steve Gorman
sports sent me this this link to this
this country star that's been that's
been struggling for a long long time he
finally got a big break I believe he's a
distant cousin of Rory Clark I'm not
sure but his name is wheeler Walker jr.
and he sent me a clip that I'll send you
guys it's a great [ __ ] song for
Valentine's Day if you're not in a
relationship for a man or a woman and
the hook has just been stuck in my head
and I really want to sing it to you but
it's gonna ruin it for you so go look up
wheeler Walker jr. well I guess the song
kind of ruins it's called [ __ ] you [ __ ]
and it's really catchy and it's I don't
know it's rich kind of poetic I really
think the the chorus really sums up what
you feel when somebody breaks your heart
so you know country music those country
music stars they can do that tea every
once in a while and it's nice to see
someone go to the left
you know those [ __ ] country singers
says those poor bastards for all these
[ __ ] years you know they've been
abusing drugs
you know going to Klan meetings and
beating the [ __ ] out of their women but
when they get on TV they got to do that
Family Values thing you know they got to
get I just want to thank Jesus and I'm
just I just feel blessed that y'all just
you've taken me into your hearts you
know hey yeah oh you want some potato
salad that stupid phony [ __ ] southern
thing where if you're from up north the
first time you see it your heart and
melts when you hear that twang and you
just think to dig the nicest [ __ ]
person nobody is dick the [ __ ] knife
in your back like a [ __ ] southerner
with that [ __ ] hey y'all [ __ ] here on
Facebook and they downplay it to play
dumb but blah blah blah blah blah and
next thing you know you're laying in a
[ __ ] pig trough about ready to get
[ __ ] eaten alive that's how it goes
down all right that guy from [ __ ] 50
snatches and 40 Smoking Barrels that's
where we got it from okay not from that
[ __ ] you know I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about
anyways I watched a brand new TV show
last night and I was really [ __ ]
disappointed you know I [ __ ] turned
it on I needed a new show and I thought
it was gonna be the one you know I was
like this is gonna be it it's
Valentine's Day night okay me and the
lovely Nia we're not going out I had a
[ __ ] one of those tomahawk steaks
frozen in the fries the [ __ ] right
defrosted that [ __ ] all day I watched
like 30 YouTube videos as hard dude sad
do you know if you're gonna do one more
to do it stores all concerned I watched
like 50 those [ __ ] things and I just
sort of like I took a survey with
temperature and time slippage in all of
that stuff and I went down the middle
and I got a little impatient with the
big green egg my temperatures a little
higher than I wanted so came out of the
medium rather than a medium rare but it
was still [ __ ] delish and there was a
new series that that that I tried to get
into last night and I put it on and
look good the acting was great but the
dialogue just wasn't there and I tried
to [ __ ] fight it out for the first
twenty minutes and then I just looked
over at Nia Nia did one of those yeah
you know big inhale and the [ __ ] eyes
like yeah this is yeah and then I was
just like well let's shut it up she's
like no you know we gotta at least watch
the pilot episode you know which is how
she ended up marrying me because I
believe twenty minutes into our
relationship she was like yeah but she
[ __ ] stuck it through night she kept
panning for gold and she found a little
nugget and she stuck with me I didn't I
was just like [ __ ] this I'm out and by
40 minutes into it I was imitating
people in it and the whole thing just
went down the [ __ ] so once again but
you know what
you know I'm not finally gonna do I
think I'm finally gonna start watching
Game of Thrones now that they're [ __ ]
five ten fifteen [ __ ] seasons into it
I've been trying to watch it for the
longest time but Nia's just not into it
you know she doesn't see a bunch of
white people running around chasing
dragons it's just not what she's into
and I'm not really into dragons either
but like if you're gonna cut somebody's
[ __ ] head off like I'm you know you
got to do a lot to lose me after that
point you know I don't know maybe I
don't know who the [ __ ] knows maybe I
remember watching the first one and
there was some sort of spooky thing
going on and there was some little kid
that was supposed to watch a beheading
and he looked away and then his I figure
out what his dad did put him on the rack
or something I don't remember but then I
don't I don't know what happened and
that just kept it kept going and you
know it was like a train that was coming
right and you could have ran and caught
it but I thought you don't you just
stand there and you watch it disappear
and in that moment when that train
disappears and you realize you're late
for work in that [ __ ] moment you
question everything that you're doing in
your life why didn't I run for that
train because I have this job that I
don't like what am i doing in this
relationship what happened to me
what happened last six years of my
[ __ ] life right it's a critical
moment there where you have to beat all
those thoughts down bury them and go
back to being the zombie that you are
which brings me to the walking dead no
I'm kidding
anyways I want to thank everyone who
came out in Cheyenne Wyoming I kept
doing a southern accent the entire time
I was out there and I was addressing it
but uh I don't know what Wyoming people
sound like Cheyenne Wyoming and Denver
Colorado I went out with Dean Del Rey
and we had the great [ __ ] time to
plate this
the Cheyenne Civic Center how cool does
that sound had all this amazing woodwork
inside of it that really looked like one
of those log cabins that either an oil
man or a [ __ ] Hollywood starlet goes
and buys you know like when people like
it a huge amount of success pretending
to be other people at some point they
have to get out of LA and then they
always end up in like Wyoming or Montana
it's [ __ ] hilarious and they buy a
what looks like a log cabin sort of it
looks like a log cabin and like a
[ __ ] resort all at the same time you
know and then they go out there and they
buy their designer I'm a [ __ ] cattle
rancher wardrobe and then they do the
[ __ ] interview right with a big
stupid cowboy hat on and older wiser
so-and-so steps back to evaluate the
last six years of a whirlwind whatever
the [ __ ] it is right you don't I mean
and then they pretend that they can live
this little [ __ ] life out there
before they go nuts after three days and
they call up a g5 to pick them up and
take them right back you know and they
end up back down the chateau
all right the Chateau mom all do it blow
on a bungalow that's what you do you
find in a little bit of balance oh
speaking of [ __ ] it's before I go back
on that [ __ ] speaking of [ __ ] sick
ass houses I was I went on this Paul
Newman kick you know he's my favorite of
all time you know a lot of people go
Steve McQueen I like Steve McQueen but
Paul Newman's my guy
he's my fella I just I don't know once I
look into those blue eyes I just I melt
just say anything I believe it are you a
pool shark are you a lawyer
do you play hockey
I watched well I guess the first thing I
watched I watched the man with the
Golden Arm which which Delray was
telling me to watch which was a movie
above Frank Sinatra playing a heroin
addict who you know comes out of jail
and he gets clean and he plays the drums
and he wants to get a gig playing drums
and I watched a great [ __ ] movie
there's some brutal brutal overacting
you got I don't know I would definitely
recommend seeing that so once I finished
that you know it's like the next thing
that was coming up was somebody up there
likes me which I'd always heard of when
I was growing up and then once I saw it
was Paul Newman I was like all right I'm
gonna watch it and it was him playing
out rocky Graziano the rocky Graziano
story and and I literally forget what I
was talking oh that's right that's right
so they just got me on this this this
Paul Newman thing and you know what's
funny is this thing actually Steve
McQueen is in that movie for [ __ ] two
seconds and it's right as Graziano is
getting out of some [ __ ] you know
Juvenile Detention home that he [ __ ]
escapes so he's going around the
neighborhood tapping all these guys all
this tough-guy friends on the shoulders
to be like hey I'm back in the
neighborhood and all of them turn around
like who the [ __ ] is this guy right cuz
because they're tough Street kids so
[ __ ] [ __ ] Steve McQueen his
shooting pull the rocky taps him on the
shoulder and he [ __ ] turns around
with a knife out just in two seconds and
then he realizes it's freeze like it's
Rocky he's like a Rocky and he does this
stupid [ __ ] thing with his hand that
I don't know who [ __ ] there's certain
things in movies that the first guy who
plays that guy does and then it's this
weird [ __ ] thing where every other
actor
after it starts [ __ ] doing it and you
know nobody ever did it who's actually
the guy that they're playing but then
it's done enough in [ __ ] movies that
the people who are actually a guy then
they start [ __ ] doing it and that's
when it becomes a circle and you don't
know who the [ __ ] is it's this
[ __ ] thing like it's almost like say
you were getting a manicure right and
you wanted to dry off your nails and you
just see like a Rakhi he's doing this
stupid [ __ ] thing with this hand I
don't know I'm going a really long way
here to tell you what I really want to
tell you but like one of my favorite
things is to watch actors during that
era playing tough street kids like it's
just it's [ __ ] cringe-worthy that
[ __ ] movie that Marlon Brando did
he's on the motorcycle what the [ __ ] was
that one called it's not the Wild Bunch
that was a cowboy movie rebel without a
cart now that's James Dean I can't
remember but just the do you have to sit
there and watch that [ __ ] how [ __ ]
brutal it is that West Side Story which
I don't think I've ever seen I'm just
gonna throw that in there because I need
three of them I don't know whatever so I
started watching that so then I finished
that one and then the next one that came
on I can't even remember the name of it
[ __ ] hang on a second I got a IMDB
[ __ ] Paul Newman he just has the
bluest eyes Paul Newman IMD [ __ ] it'd be
filmography so anyways I think was
called nut Hudson the long story was
this next movie comes on right and in
the beginning he's driving in this car
and he's clearly in Los Angeles which
was one of my favorite [ __ ] things
ever to just see old footage
black-and-white or color of LA and he
just get to see like you can usually
tell by the Hollywood Hills and
sometimes the highways and [ __ ] kind of
where they are and you'll see like train
tracks and [ __ ] that they ripped up
those [ __ ] [ __ ] or you'll see you
know you'll just see how less populated
is alright here it is Harper Harper's
the movie the very
beginning the movie he goes into a house
and Lauren Bacall's in there Lauren
Bacall who married Humphrey Bogart bogie
and Bacall one of the great couples in
Hollywood history and you know
Humphrey Bogart something that Frank
Sinatra stole a lot of his swagger from
they were also the first Rat Pack
Humphrey Bogart and all his [ __ ] crew
and not only did Sinatra steal a lot of
Humphrey Bogart swagger he actually
ended up [ __ ] Lauren Bacall later on
after Humphrey Bogart died which is
really [ __ ] up but anyways I digress
so at Harper he pulls into this [ __ ]
house that I could not believe and I
actually looked it up and it still
exists look it up right now if you're at
work pretend that you're doing that
you're doing some sort of busy work it's
it's on one zero one one North Beverly
Drive ten eleven Beverly Drive and this
[ __ ] house I think it's just called
the Beverly House it's in Beverly Hills
probably has one of the sickest [ __ ]
pools I've ever seen in my life
it's like a three-tiered thing the first
two tiers I believe are just considered
a waterfall and first of all it has like
a half mile driveway that he comes up
around and what's hilarious which looks
like the first year they had the Porsche
which at this point by 1965 when they
shot it was just considered a piece of
[ __ ] who would know that years later
some baby boomer would play like [ __ ]
900 grand Ford so he's driving up one of
you know one of the fenders is like that
[ __ ] you know what's that that paint
that they primered and all that [ __ ] so
he pulls up in this [ __ ] house you
got to see the backyard of it so
actually I look the [ __ ] thing up I
found out where it was and the next time
I fly a helicopter I'm gonna [ __ ] fly
over the house and check it out it's
actually just a little bit north of the
Beverly Hills hotel but you got to check
this [ __ ] thing out one of the great
things about living in Los Angeles a lot
of people you know always [ __ ] on living
in LA but one of them eight I think
arguably has some of the most amazing
homes in the country just for the simple
fact that for whatever reason I don't
know if it's the weather out here or
what
they haven't been torn down so many of
them you know other places that I've
been to but they have like Craftsman
houses out here and then they have all
the the Spanish the Mediterranean style
ones they have they got it's just
incredible houses so you got to check
this one out this house is actually kind
of ugly you know when you pull up they
shot the Godfather Part two there but I
part one there this is actually the
house where the horse's head seen
spoiler alert if you have one of the two
people have never seen that [ __ ]
movie they shot that scene in there and
JFK and his wife Jackie had their
honeymoon in this [ __ ] house and I
just saw it recently the last time it's
sold it sold for a hundred thirty-five
million dollars and all I'm doing
looking at it after buying my old ass
house that was made in 1923 all I see is
[ __ ] fifty thousand-square-foot of
galvanized pipe and cloth wiring that
they're gonna have to somehow [ __ ]
read through where well sections of it
you know there's a little bit of copper
pipe air a little bit of wiring that was
done correctly but anyways that's
another cool thing about these [ __ ]
houses out there is that they've been
around so long and if they're in a
desirable area in Hollywood like the
stories of like the people that live
there like how cool I mean that's 135
million dollar house obviously be a
[ __ ] amazing house but how [ __ ]
you know amazing would be to have that
house and be like you didn't see a movie
and you're watching Paul Newman walking
across your [ __ ] Terrace that you now
honor I don't know I think that shit's
cool is help but you know why you're a t
he can check out a lot of those and also
just look up famous Hollywood homes I
told you there's a house about not even
like I don't know me
a 15 minute drive away from me in Los
Angeles 15 minutes is a big [ __ ] deal
sometimes just you know 15 blocks it can
go one way or another it can literally
go like - I'm gonna get stabbed - how
the [ __ ] can you ever afford to live in
so how many people did you steal from to
get this [ __ ] this guy's got a moat
around his house that's less way LA is
it's like really like patchwork so like
a 15 minute drive away from where I live
my neighbor told me there's a house that
went up for sale I think I told this
story before and it's an old-ass house
it's pre-prohibition
and basically when Prohibition came
around this house had a pool and then it
had a Cabana and in the Cabana at this
guy he built a bar during Prohibition
and he had a legal booze or I don't know
if he was making beer in the bathtub
whatever the [ __ ] he was doing but he
used to he used to have all these famous
people come over there and they would
just booze it up and he anybody who came
over there and drank that was famous he
would have him carved their names into
the bar and evidently according to my
neighbor who went and looked at the
house even though he couldn't afford it
he just wanted to see the bar he went
and looked at it and it's one of those
things if you buy the house it's that
bar is obviously protected by the
Historical Society some [ __ ] but you go
in there and everyone from like Louis
Armstrong to like [ __ ] Humphrey
Bogart have carved their names into that
[ __ ] bar so whatever that's some sort
of nerdy Los Angeles house [ __ ] but yeah
definitely rather than work today just
go on Google Earth and just look at some
of those [ __ ] houses or just Google
like famous Hollywood homes - this homes
were like you know when I was watching
that
you know somebody up there likes me or I
should really know the name of the
[ __ ] actress the one who plays Paul
Newman's love interest obviously is an
absolute [ __ ] knockout and I'd never
heard of her so the fact that I never
heard of her I'm like [ __ ] I've looked
up
enough of those those old movies like I
got this creepy thing that I always look
people up like an older person like
alright that person is definitely dead
let's see how long that they lived for
right or you try to find a cast where
like everybody's dead you know which is
a very difficult thing to do so anyways
so I started looking up you know the
people that were you know this woman I
hope I say her name right it's P ier is
it Pierre Pete Pierre I don't know
and and jelly I have no idea I looked
her up and I was immediately going like
she probably died of pills because back
then like I don't know like getting
given people pills like it seems back
then every guy either died of a heart
attack in his 50s and 60s or he died at
cancer and like 90% of the women died of
an accidental like barbiturate overdose
because back then like you know the
woman came in and she had some emotional
issues you know the doctors like for
God's sake get all to yourself and they
would just give her some pills to relax
her it was like in that movie airplane
where they were just slapping you and
giving you a backhand and [ __ ] so she
was just gorgeous amazing actress and
then of course I looked it up and you
know she died accidentally
some people say suicide some people say
accidentally at 39 years of age and then
I look it up and sure enough the place
where she [ __ ] overdosed is still
there that's another one of those things
it's a really [ __ ] you know it's
either cool or creepy all these [ __ ]
houses that people died in there's
another actor in there this guy's Sal
Mineo or whatever I swear to God who's a
dead ringer for Ralph Macchio he's in it
and he ended he got [ __ ] stabbed to
death in like the mid-70s it's [ __ ]
unreal man like a lot of people a lot of
stars back in the day they didn't make
it they didn't [ __ ] ride it out it
seemed like just crazy [ __ ] happened to
him and I guess what I'm saying is that
a lot of these houses still exist and if
you're sort of them I guess I'm becoming
morbid in my older ages I realize you
know
you know it made your mortality you
start looking how long this person live
how do they live how did they die [ __ ]
is that gonna happen to me you know that
type of [ __ ] I don't know all right
let's uh let's read let's read a little
[ __ ] advertising here for the week
would you look at their MV MT watches
movement watches this company ladies and
gentlemen was started by two college
dropouts with the idea to make quality
watches that don't break the goddamn
bank they started just 95 bucks they're
sold online so they cut out all the
[ __ ] retail markup movement watches
since some over here and I got to tell
you man you throw one on your wrist
nobody has any idea that it's not a
really expensive watch unless they sell
watches or they come over and they touch
it and they realize it's a lot lighter
quality materials and sleek designs the
perfect everyday watch it's easy order
online today for free shipping free
returns and a 24 month warranty
join the movement and say no to big
brand retail markups and say yes to
great styles check out MV mt watches
dot-com / bar and you'll get 15% off
your entire purchase
that's mV mt watches dot-com / / alright
the next one Dollar Shave Club everybody
you know lots of players will be
sporting playoff beards now that the
post seasons here they got update this
leave that to the pros kick off the your
year right kick off your year the right
way sorry with the fresh blade shave
that's why me and millions of others
have joined the Dollar Shave Club have
joined dollarshaveclub.com you know I
realize about me reading out loud my
[ __ ] mouth is like I've sentenced and
a half where my [ __ ] eyes are slow it
down bill Dollar Shave Club knows the
key to getting an amazing shave is
simple one use a fresh Dollar Shave Club
blade to use there dr. Chavez easy
that's it doc Dollar Shave Club delivers
amazing razors right to my door for a
third of the price of those greedy mega
razor corporations that means listeners
who switched now can afford the luxury
of shaving with a fresh blade any time
and save hundreds this year
and when you combine the fresh blade
with their doctor copies easy shave
Plata it just glides
it's unimaginably smooth I'm telling you
if you're not it's not your average
shave foam it won't dry out your skin be
all natural ingredients leave your skin
feeling soft smooth and moisturized
after every shaved shape sorry take it
from me take it from somebody else
but whatever don't take it do whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do use a fresh
Dollar Shave Club blade with Josh you
can have these easy shape letter if you
wanted the most gentle shape imaginable
dollarshaveclub.com slash bird today huh
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash / oh by
the way I'm doing my first solo flight
through bravo airspace so if you're
still on the map if you're still on the
Google Earth math I love looking at this
[ __ ] right and you go on to you go on to
what do you do when you click it on the
[ __ ] globe there alright now go over
to the ocean okay follow Santa Monica
Boulevard over to the ocean all right
right where it says 210 now go down a
little bit and you'll see something that
kind of looks like a tree but it's made
out of water that's Marina del Rey
alright now if you're flying south
that's where bravo airspace begins along
the coastline and when you're there you
have to be at a hundred fifty feet or
below at or below 150 and then you
transition the bravo airspace if you go
a little bit further south you'll see
LAX
alright and that's to the south event is
two five right into five left into the
north there's two five right two five
left those two run
and those were the big boys had taken
off so you fly underneath those guys or
ladies and you stay at or below 150 feet
until you get to and then you got to
zoom in the Manhattan Beach Pier and
which is almost a beam as they say the
comedy and magic club down on Hermosa
Beach so you want to be you want to be
right down there 150 [ __ ] goddamn
feet now wait a minute wouldn't it be
Hermosa yeah and I'm sorry how most of
Beach Pier is where the comedy clubs
that but the Manhattan Beach Pier
that's where you want to be you guys
from from there to Marina del Rey you
got to be at or below 150 feet so if you
come out here and you're on the beach as
a tourist you see these helicopters
flying by really low they're not buzzing
the beach looking at year or whatever
they are they are transitioning the
bravo airspace so I'm gonna be doing
that I don't know on what day but that's
my big goal this week with the
helicopter thing there but anyways let's
get back to the skip back to the podcast
here where is it what the hell's did I
want to talk about oh how about those
Boston Bruins now I know we lost I know
we lost to the Red Wings I didn't get to
see the the game yet I haven't taped I'm
a game behind
I watched the I'm actually gaming
two-thirds behind I watched the first
quarter of of us beating the wild and
Brad Marshawn scored again his 12th goal
in 12 games and I actually looked up the
tech and I saw that he scored his 13th
[ __ ] goal and in 13 games the guy's
on fire and I saw his goal in the the
Minnesota Wild game a short-handed goal
just a beautiful pass and I was [ __ ]
awesome and he's gonna have like at skis
on his way he's gonna have like 40 goals
is [ __ ] here and I gotta say just the
Bruins and the Celtics this year both of
them I was just going to be like that
this is you know after all them
they made you know I just kind of felt
that neither one was gonna be that
competitive and it was gonna be tough to
watch him this year and I am I think
they're both overachieve and it's been
fun to watch him although for some
reason my [ __ ] recorder stopped
taping the Celtics game so I was really
getting into it watching Isiah Thomas
and Crowder Jae Crowder and I was jam
band guy I finally learned his [ __ ]
name there Kelly Olynyk right I was
enjoying watching it and our young coach
there who I still don't know his [ __ ]
name because I always taped the games
and they talked to him and I just
fast-forward through all of that [ __ ]
and then they just show him I think his
name Stan Stephen something with an S
Shawn I don't know but he looks like a
baby man the guy's like [ __ ] 15 years
younger than me and he's coaching the
Celtics he's doing a great job and
evidently we got a couple of number-one
draft picks we're in a great [ __ ]
position
I missed the all-star weekend stuff I
saw some of the dunking stuff and Kevin
Hart did anybody see Kevin Hart he went
up against some other NBA guy I can tell
I don't watch his [ __ ] NBA he went up
against a professional basketball player
in a three-point contest should I give
you a spoiler alert or should I do that
the clickbait and the results will
surprise you it gives a [ __ ] he actually
beat the guy and what I loved about it
besides being a big fan of his stuff and
everything was when he went to start
shooting his three-pointers they were
playing disrespectful music underneath
em they were playing this always in this
light oh it's adorable or isn't it silly
that this little man is gonna come out
here and try and beat one of our
professional athletes and they were
right through the first two racks and
then he [ __ ] closed strong and I
think he might have beat him on the last
ball you got to see it Matt I mean it's
uh it's pretty [ __ ] impressive if I
remember correctly a long time ago he
was telling me that before he was a
comedian he went to a
you know he went to a basketball camp
that had a young unknown Kobe Bryant and
that type of [ __ ] so but still man you
know it was a long [ __ ] time ago
since then he's gone all the way to
selling out
the Eagles football stadium doing
stand-up comedy you'd think that his
basketball game would drop off a little
bit that maybe he'd be a little rusty at
the Y forget about being able to beat a
[ __ ] NBA player in a three-point
contest it was pretty pretty goddamn
impressive
so anyway somebody get back Jesus Christ
Wyoming Cheyenne so I go there and you
know this was the last of the 50 that I
had to do so of course I'm reading all
up on Wyoming and all that type of stuff
and I see that Yellowstone Park is right
in the north northwest corner of it I'm
like well [ __ ] I got to go up there and
go do a gig in the middle of nowhere at
some point and maybe I'll do a nice run
through Montana Idaho and all that [ __ ]
the Dakotas you know I get into all that
[ __ ] nerdy [ __ ] right so we do the
gig we have a great time it takes some
pictures with some people afterwards and
when I was onstage I was saying hey
where should we go tonight if I want to
go out and have a pot right so of course
everybody's yelling out everything at
the same time and I can't hear anything
so I'm like one at a time one at a time
and then just in the back this guy yells
out said to go to the green door and
then the whole crowd just goes ah like
you know don't go there and I was like I
was like I don't even need you guys to
say that the green door just sounds like
some creepy serial killer place so I go
I'm not [ __ ] going there so then
somebody said by forget the [ __ ] it was
called the Cadillac lounge or something
I took a picture of it so I I decide you
know all right that's where the [ __ ]
we'll go we'll go over to this thing I'm
actually looking up the picture right
now am i my phone here come on come on
where is it where is it there it is the
Cadillac Cadillac Ranch sorry
so we go in there you know there's a big
American flag lit up on the side I'm
like all right here we go let's [ __ ]
go in there and see what this place is
about and we went in there and I got to
tell you man it was the most diverse
group of [ __ ] people I've ever seen
in my life and I think for the simple
fact there was no other place to go so
there was like a group of bikers there
was there was soldiers there was like
Ranchers there was a group of lesbians
and there was just filler people that
you couldn't really tell what the [ __ ]
they were they was older younger the
whole [ __ ] thing so we're in there
like wow man look this is [ __ ] this
is nuts and then it had a real like
cowboy kind of feel to it yet there was
like a [ __ ] DJ playing like modern
music it was this it was [ __ ] so we're
in there and Dean for whatever [ __ ]
reason it's just pointing at [ __ ] and
people going look at that [ __ ] guy
look at this [ __ ] look at his [ __ ]
bar and I'm sitting there going Dean
stop pointing at [ __ ] stop pointing [ __ ]
you know what Dean's been sober for like
20 [ __ ] years so he's got no excuse
he just kept pointed [ __ ] and then
finally you know I had a you know I was
talking to a couple of the people in
there talking this guy that was in the
middle of taking a two-year welding
class which of course was really
interesting to me I was talking about
that [ __ ] I was talking to some other
people and then at one point somebody
said hey you want a a whiskey so like my
thing now when I go on the road and I
drink I have a beer and a you know
whiskey or a scotch and then that's it I
call it a [ __ ] night and it's been
working out great for me you know what I
mean so I have a nice little taste but
then I don't get hammered then I'm fine
the next morning I could have workout
and [ __ ] right so this guy offers you
know it comes over a you know I got to
buy a drink I said I'm just getting a
beer and I said all right well you know
I was gonna get a whiskey too he goes
what do you want he goes we got a local
[ __ ] Wyoming whiskey I was like all
right when he's shy let's [ __ ] do it
right so he gets me this [ __ ] shot
and he brings it over and it looked it
was almost like see-through now I don't
know if they did whiskey and water or
what but I [ __ ] took a sip of it and
I had no
or anything I was just looking I'm like
dude what the [ __ ] is is he goes he goes
well it hasn't been aged at all I gotta
tell you do it was the worst whiskey
I've ever had and my apology to the
person who bought me this shot I
couldn't finish it I look I said Dina go
look at this [ __ ] thing and Dean was
just like yeah dude that looks like piss
so and at that point I wasn't looking
but Dean was saying that the biker
people were mean muggin everybody and he
goes - lets get the [ __ ] out of here so
we get out of there
and oh as we were driving over there I
noticed that there was a drive there was
a liquor store with a drive-through so I
was like oh god I got to get a picture
of that so I get it I pulled over I get
a picture of it and then I'm just like
dude I got to do it I got to go to a
drive-through liquor store so I [ __ ]
pull up we actually I posted video of
this and I just wanted to get one beer
and the guy goes why I can give you like
the 24 ounce so I got like a Budweiser
I'll repost the video on the the Monday
morning podcast Twitter page so I went
up I ordered a [ __ ] beer you know what
was really cool is it had the old [ __ ]
it remember the old air hoses when you
would pull up at the the the gas station
and it would ring the bell like ding
ding is your car pulled in it was so
[ __ ] cool and we was sitting there
and then this dude just sort of walked
into the place or whatever and as we
drive out there's an Arby's across the
street which I never [ __ ] eat
you know [ __ ] fast-food roast roast
beef I mean I like to think I'm a
courageous person but that's just a
little
that's that gets a little too shady for
me right I'd rather eat the pink slime
so anyways Del Rey's going like came in
I guess let's hit the Arby's I'm hungry
so I got alright so we go into the
Arby's right he orders some [ __ ] that I
ordered like some chicken sliders which
I shouldn't have [ __ ] caught they
were [ __ ] disgusting it was like
eating the heel of some chicks [ __ ]
boot boot you know just the way they
were shaped like clogs they were just
[ __ ] gross so we go around to the
drive-thru and this is right across from
the drive-through liquor store and look
across the street and I read the sign
and what does it say
it's
as the green door so the drive-through
liquor store is part of this shady
[ __ ] titty bar called the green door
that urban legend said that there was a
one-legged stripper and now the younger
me would have been like I got to go in
and go see that [ __ ] the older me goes
like oh my god that's somebody's
daughter so so technically I kind of did
go to the green door I didn't I didn't
go in there I just [ __ ] pulled up or
whatever so I'll I'll post some pictures
of that [ __ ] let me see if I actually
took him so and then the next day we got
up right and we wanted to go to some
local place to get a to get breakfast
and we went to this local place and I
don't know if the regular chef was out
of town but I ordered eggs over-easy and
I cut into him dude they were so
undercooked like it came out clear like
the white part of the egg was still
clear like you know when those people
drink like egg whites it was like that
and so Dean's eggs were the same way
and I just never sent food back so I
just stirred him in with the [ __ ]
hash I mean they should have just served
the eggs in a glass like [ __ ] Rocky
Balboa and I just suck it down and I
noticed a woman diagonally from me she
sent her eggs back too and then in the
end when I went to I went to pay she was
just like how was it and when I said it
was great I kind of stumbled on when it
was good it was great and then she goes
so that she me looked up she goes is
everything okay was everything okay so
I'm just guessing that the the normal
chef was out of town so I'm not going to
out this place as being a as being
something bad but uh it was pretty rough
it was one of the worst breakfast 'iz
I've ever had but uh when we when we
came back down we were driving down to
Denver I'd leave to feel like a little
kid right now like I'm just telling you
every moment of this [ __ ] this tour
but uh Dean's a big motorcycle guy Ben
Ryan for 30 years so they had this huge
[ __ ] Harley Davidson dealership right
on the 25 as we were coming down so he
stopped in and I didn't know but Harley
has a new bike that's just right out of
my childhood it's called the 72
and it's got the big spoke front wheel
it's got the handlebars it's like [ __ ]
Arthur Fonzarelli spike which obviously
was [ __ ] from this thing you know the
50s or whatever but I haven't ridden in
like a year and a half and I don't know
man I think I got to ride that bike I
think I'm gonna rent it just one day
there's a park up around where I'm at
I'm rented on like a Sunday and just go
up there in the morning time and just
[ __ ] riding around and bring it back
I'm too much of a [ __ ] to ride all the
time cuz you know I got too much to
[ __ ] lose and oh my god they had one
in this black and gold metal flake it
was [ __ ] good just perfect man as
much as I love the road King like every
wannabe motorcycle rider who watched a
couple episodes of whatever that [ __ ]
show was what was that [ __ ] show
there that everybody watched about about
the bikes you know like every [ __ ]
wannabe badass who doesn't have a tattoo
and it's not a motorcycle guy like
delray took a picture of me on the
[ __ ] 70 that's 72 and I just started
laughing I was like how much how much am
I not a motorcycle guy like do you
realize if what a [ __ ] nerd you have
to look like to sit on a Harley and
still look like a [ __ ] sit still look
like somebody you could bully here I
[Music]
look like every [ __ ] just white dude
having a midlife crisis that like you
know who watch that what is that [ __ ]
show what is the [ __ ] show that was
all about the motorcycles that everybody
watched I never got into it god damn it
it's the perfect reference for this [ __ ]
but anyways I might have to rent one
coming up might go ride a dirt bike and
get my [ __ ] my skills back up to the
ridiculously low level that they were I
just go to a local park out here and I
just drive this loop around and around
and around it's actually good because
there's a lot of downshift in that [ __ ]
a lot of turns you got to look your way
through all this [ __ ] that I learned in
the safety course and everything but
like I told you guys one time when I
rode a motorcycle down sunset all the
way out to the beach just like I wanted
to just thinking
is gonna feel like you know freedom and
America right I was gonna see all this
[ __ ] dude I didn't see [ __ ]
I was [ __ ] terrified there was just
too many [ __ ] people and you know we
went later than I wanted to go I rode
with Dean and Dean you know I'd done
spot so he didn't get up to like ten so
we didn't get on the road till like 11
and I wanted to go like 7 in the [ __ ]
morning when there was nobody on the
road and really just be able to relax a
little bit and not have somebody right
behind me and I just remember getting
off the bike and I was like shaking and
I was just like I had to have that
[ __ ] get out of your ego moment and
just be like Bill this isn't in you you
don't have this in your blood you're not
a motorcycle [ __ ] guy he's just not
so don't be that [ __ ] and I
immediately sold the bike or got rid of
it whatever the [ __ ] I did I don't even
remember but um I don't know I think
every once in a while if you know I
smoked a couple cigars a month I got
that under control if every once in a
while I ran a motorcycle and I know
everybody's gonna [ __ ] be like Oh Oh
Joey Ward Rouge because you're gonna be
[ __ ] rusty I write taking all the fun
out of everything
all right oh also this week I got back
into like drinking juices and [ __ ] and
there was this [ __ ] algae [ __ ] which
was disgusting when I drank it but I
felt amazing afterwards and I'm trying
to you know like Dean said you know it's
a good addiction to have like you get
addicted this [ __ ]
III realized that and if you're addicted
to like working out good stuff that's
obviously a much better thing for you so
am I trying to get back into that type
of stuff but anyways this this past
weekend on Saturday night when I got
back I went to a this music music cares
event and every year they honor somebody
and whoever they're honoring everybody
comes out and just does this person's
music so say they were honoring ac/dc a
bunch of famous [ __ ] musicians that
are into ac/dc would come out and do all
their songs and switch them up
do different versions of him so is
Lionel Richie right
oh what a feelin right so I go to this
[ __ ] thing and it was unreal it was
like Lenny Kravitz
uh sure who I couldn't believe how small
he was he [ __ ] crushed it John Legend
Stevie Wonder all right all these
monsters and then Stevie Wonder and I
knew Dave Grohl was gonna go on and I
might kind of [ __ ] his Dave Grohl gonna
follow this is he gonna play drums and
sing is he gonna do the come out with
his blue guitar and sing and he just
went up and just sang a song that was it
he told this [ __ ] story about you
know when he broke his leg
remember he fell off the stage well he
broke his leg he was talking about all
the outpouring from the fans and all
that and then one day he just got this
giant [ __ ] basket of muffins the
biggest basket I guess ever this [ __ ]
giant thing and there was no note or
anything on it and he's he's telling
this story that the band sort of just
playing you know some music underneath
it and he's telling this story he's got
people laughing but they're listening
and all that [ __ ] and then like two days
later I guess he got a he got a call
from his manager who said yeah Lionel
Richie's Lionel Richie just called up to
see if you got the [ __ ] giant basket
of muffins and then he just goes so I
just you know I forget how we [ __ ]
ended the story I'm butchering it now
right as he ends the store and you
realized that it was Lionel Richie they
kick into that his song you are a Dave
Grohl just crushed it you know that song
you are this something you are the brain
and he just was up there singing it
[ __ ] crushed it went on after Stevie
Wonder and crushed it so I got that I
got to do that you know it was funny was
uh I went down there and you know I'm
not a suit guy but you had to wear like
a shirt and tie dude and I swear to God
like I don't know just like me when I
was on the motorcycle when I I had on
that suit and tie dude I don't know what
it was sometimes I look alright but uh
the thing
about suits is if you if you you gotta
buy him like they go out of style really
quick and this one was like three four
years old I just gotten a dry clean to
some show the last time I wore it and I
put this [ __ ] thing on and I was
talking to me I was like I just kept
going I looked like an [ __ ] right
like she's like no you look fine I got
ya I don't think so I look like an
[ __ ] so the whole [ __ ] night
you know any time I would walk into the
bathroom you know it was a long [ __ ]
night was like a four-hour [ __ ] thing
you know and any time I would go in
there and I would wash my hands I would
just sit there and I would look at
myself in the mirror I just kept
laughing what a [ __ ] jerk-off I look
like I know it wasn't a good scene you
know I don't like hate myself it's not a
good place for me to be like to say I
think it's time to retire that suit
alright let's get into some of the some
of the [ __ ] questions here for the
week here we go judge Scalia bill
listener from Virginia hear the death of
judge Scalia brought out some jokes on
social media and a lot of people took
the angle that they were happy that he
died now I'm assuming this is somebody
on the Supreme Court because I don't pay
attention this [ __ ] but I did see some
stuff about this is the first time the
Supreme Court won't be conservative
because what's your position on making
jokes about being happy people died
thanks for the for for that laughs I
think you mean thank you thanks for the
laughs
my position on making joke about weight
yeah I think you got a B I think you got
to be like a dictator for people to do
[ __ ] like that yeah I mean I wouldn't
say don't do it because there's always a
joke I mean someday when I die there's
gonna be a joke I mean I'm play now and
if I'm hovering around as a ghost I'm
gonna laugh about it what the [ __ ] do I
care I'm a ghost at that point right I
didn't go to hell all right I'm floating
around I could deal with this but yeah I
don't do that
well look if you just make a joke joke
that's fine but if you're doing it
because you didn't share like their
political views yeah I'm not into doing
that type of [ __ ] like you know some
some [ __ ] I'm gonna start doing this
like the [ __ ] tweet of the week
somebody sent me a text today telling me
that I needed to distance myself bill
just to let you know you need to
distance yourself from so-and-so and
then sent me a link and this is
something that I've been friends with
for 20 [ __ ] years and then I see this
link and it has to do with being a
vegetarian or eating meat and the name
of the video is so-and-so is an ignorant
[ __ ] which right there I love like
that's your angle like to get someone to
listen to your opinion right there I
just look at it like this is just this
is just somebody trying to make a name
for themselves trashing somebody that
that has made a name for themselves you
know with some over-the-top title first
of all I love is an ignorant [ __ ] like
that's like redundant you know he's a
stupid not smart person like I need to
distance myself from stuff from someone
who's been a great friend for 20 years
because of their dietary decisions you
know because they talk about food and
nutrition in a way that's the truth that
they believe in all this you know like
and then and what you're a [ __ ]
genius you know and it's just you know I
don't know I don't know why people do
[ __ ] like that so that kind of ties into
and I would never obviously you know but
just I don't know I would never tweeted
somebody like that you need to distance
yourself from this person because I
don't agree with their workout regimen
and the same thing with like that like
if I I wouldn't be happy that somebody
died because I didn't like their
political views you know what I mean I
always have that my head they had
somebody's dead somebody's husband or
some [ __ ] you know whatever if he was a
gay judge that's somebody's boyfriend
right I don't [ __ ] know yeah I don't
do [ __ ] like that but if somebody does
you know I'm not the comedy [ __ ]
police
all right summer home bill my wife wants
to own a home by a lake in New Hampshire
that's [ __ ] awesome I'm trying to
convince her that it's cheaper to just
rent a sick house every summer for a
couple of weeks instead of paying 15
grand a year and taxes on top of the
mortgage help me sort out this business
please go [ __ ] yourself well what I
would say is you know you can rent out
your house your summer house you know
this is what I would do okay
I would I would buy that house on the
lake and then I would just rent the
whole [ __ ] thing out and then
whenever I wanted to go I would rent
some other place you know what I mean
and this is how I'm weird because I
wouldn't want to go into a place that I
owned knowing that everybody [ __ ] in
my bed I would rather go to a place
knowing that's a bunch of people [ __ ]
at somebody else's betting it makes no
sense what you should do is buy it and
then rent it out I mean buying property
is always great however if you're having
a rough time like I'm a big believer and
they'll paying down your first house you
should really pay that thing down and
get it under control
before you go and get a summer house and
I do know that in relationships when it
comes to money there's usually one
person understands it and the other
person doesn't understand it and they
want everything yesterday and you might
be a little more conservative which is
what you sound like so I you know I
would just sit down and just say look
first of all you're in a great position
cuz it doesn't sound like she can just
go out and pull the trigger herself so I
just say listen I definitely want to do
that but we need to we need to pay down
this house a little bit or you know if
we can't afford it let's buy it and then
we'll rent the thing out all the
weekends that we're not going to be
there I think that's definitely just
definitely a smart way to do it but I
would just sit down
and write out all the points that you
want to make and then draw a smiley face
this is what I do when up being a smart
person because I know how short a fuse I
have and I write all this [ __ ] out
everything that I want to say and all
that stuff and then I draw a smiley face
reminding me to not lose my temper
reminding me that other people are
entitled to have different opinions and
you know and not to be a [ __ ] I didn't
do that a couple days ago and ended up
having a big stupid fight over the
bathroom sink you know I got on the road
and it starts started to clogged up and
I didn't have time to [ __ ] fix it but
you know we can't drain up so I figured
you know my wife would [ __ ] handle it
and I come home to brush my teeth and I
turn it on and within [ __ ] two
seconds it's already filling up as a
puddle it's completely backed up and you
know its usual [ __ ] usual [ __ ] in a
relationship you say to somebody else
did you know no I didn't notice and in
your head you're like how the [ __ ] did
you not notice this [ __ ] but what I
learned in that argument is I have to
understand that this [ __ ] that she's
looking at me at looking at me at about
like how the [ __ ] do you not notice it
and it's just because I'm just not wired
like that and that's why you get married
hopefully you're a yin and a yang I
finally said it right
I didn't say yin and yang I said Yin why
I and I think that's the first time
publicly I've ever said it right yeah
they're gonna be good at this [ __ ] that
you're not good at and actually had a
great day with Nia yesterday like I
didn't do [ __ ] for once and we just hung
out all day and you know we watched some
movies and [ __ ] you made a little bit of
food and I always forget that that every
once in a while you guys you got to hang
out with each other
rather than just being roommates to
remind yourselves like oh yeah that's
right we actually really loved each
other
I forgot about that [ __ ] and I don't the
amount of times I've had to [ __ ]
learn that you know she getting married
you really start doing the math like
dude [ __ ] this [ __ ]
I don't need anything I will literally
give her everything [ __ ] just give
you [ __ ] everything and I will walk
out with the shirt on my [ __ ] back
and I will start all over again
like I think that that's the way to
[ __ ] do it and just walk down the
street after it like Johnny [ __ ]
Appleseed and because I really think you
just get into having all of this [ __ ]
stuff but if you just let go of all of
it then you don't have it I think
getting divorce could be a really light
feeling this is how far I went over an
argument over a clogged up sink before I
came to my senses
I was walking down the street with the
with a stick with the bandanna and a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich in it
then I was just fine like what am i
doing you know it's not being a [ __ ]
idiot all right let's get to some
advertising here all right me undies
everybody oh I gotta sing this quietly
because we have company over here right
now boo boo boo me undies me undies
no more sweaty nuts but you do me undies
biondi's keep it dry with your butt's
what that doesn't make sense
ah I said nut selves thinking bus would
rhyme oh you know what I've got a retire
this [ __ ] song I need some new
[ __ ] I need some new bits on this
goddamn thing alright me undies
all right this year don't be predictable
and show up at your Valentine's Day
dinner with some last-minute box of
chocolate or bouquet of roses bouquet
bouquet I don't I said they're gonna die
in a week anyways give the gift
everyone's talking about me yon DS me on
Days taking care of your taint boo doo
doo doo me on DS biondi's your balls
will say you're a saint show your
special day that [ __ ] guy up there
he's a [ __ ] Shh show you special
someone just how much you care with the
present you'll both love a gift that
looks great and feels great something
that says you deserve the best I have to
tell you right now you if you give
somebody underwear for a gift you better
be [ __ ] them or they better be your
kid because other than
it's [ __ ] weird you know give you kid
underwear you know yeah there you go
Jesus Christ straighten up and fly right
you know have a little respect for
yourself you know and then if you you
know you wit the person intimately you
can give it to them you know there's no
[ __ ] way actually as a joke you can
do that you know you know I was actually
thinking the other day when I went to
buy my wife a Valentine's Day card you
know I was looking for the blank ones
because I hate the [ __ ] Valentine's
Day cards you know they're either
over-the-top gross other just [ __ ]
like too distant you know it's very hard
to find that one that's the nice balance
of I love you but let's not be gross so
I was looking for the blank ones and I
came to the sympathy cards and I just
was thinking like you know what I really
want to stand up with Joe DeRosa again
and then send him a sympathy card
afterwards you know tell him I hope he
feels better and everything and just
basically right Joe I saw your set last
night I know you're going through a
rough time I don't know it was funny to
me anyways let's get back to me anything
treat yourself and your boo to a
matching pair of me undies the most
world's most comfortable underwear this
comfy on this underwear as comfy as it
gets me undies are made of micro Modell
modal fabric meaning they're twice as
soft as cotton and they don't just feel
great they look right to me undies comes
in tons of cool prints and styles and
new designs come out every month you
won't want to miss miss February's
limited edition designs from the
legendary Keith Haring her ring this
retro design is inspired by love making
it the perfect Valentine's Day gift well
it's over grab yourself a pair and
celebrate the holiday sporting matching
underwear with your sweetheart how do
you do it you go to me undies dot-com /
/ now to get 20% off your first order
that's 20% off at my undies calm / /
alright stamps calm sometimes it feels
like there aren't enough sometimes it
feels like there's not enough hours than
the day you know what you're just
flustered even when you're working past
the 9:00 to 5:00 so if you're still
making time-consuming trips to the post
office you need a bed
way.you stamps come with stamps.com you
can get the postage you need the
instance you need it by and print
official US postage for any letter or
package right from your computer well in
printer you'll save money with stamps
comm - it's just a fraction of the cost
of one of those expensive postage meters
plus you'll get special postage
discounts you can't even get at the post
office I use stamps comm to send out all
my posters I'm a [ __ ] if I can figure
out how to do it so can you
right now sign up for stamps commie use
my last name ber for this special offer
four week trial plus $110 bonus software
that includes occludes postage and a
digital scale go to stamps calm before
you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Barbie URR that stamps comm
enter Berman as always if you want to
contribute to this podcast next time
you're gonna buy something on amazon.com
just go to my my website builder comm
click on the podcast page and there's a
link to Amazon all it does is take you
to Amazon doesn't cost you any more
money I just get credit for driving
traffic to this site
alright trashman everybody a billy
bubbles billy bubbles in the rain I went
to high school with a guy who picks up
my trash I get along with them and I
always wave and sometimes if he's not
rushing I'll have a short conversation
with them last week I saw my neighbor
yell at him he wasn't it he wasn't a
jerk back but he wasn't a dick either
what he wasn't a jerk back but he wasn't
a dick either later on that day my
neighbor came over and asked me if I'd
make a statement about the issue that he
harassed her I saw the whole thing go
down he didn't harass her she yelled at
him for coming at daylight during a week
when a holiday pushed everything back a
day in terms of Sanitation pickup what a
[ __ ] she said that even without my
statement she's going to press charges
and file a complaint I'm going to call
the town or police and let them know
what's going on I'm so livid that she
would ruin this guy's life he's a great
dude thoughts on how I should handle
this should I report her for lying
abso-fucking-lutely and I would take
time off from work to testify that she's
a lying [ __ ] abso-fucking-lutely what a
[ __ ] yell
a trashman the service that they're
providing [ __ ] her [ __ ] her dude you
know something I would 100% do it and I
would I would even [ __ ] tell her that
you're gonna do it at some point not not
in the beginning because you don't want
to weaken his case but I would do it
without a doubt and when the whole
[ __ ] thing goes away I would let her
know that you did that and I would let
her know what a small person you think
she is and that she's disgusting and to
stay away from you and anybody else that
you love because she's subhuman there
how was that dilemma dilemma dear bill
know what a [ __ ] [ __ ] you came at
day lateness then you harassed me gee
you know what you know you know what I
bet she does for a living she sounds
like a blogger always playing the
[ __ ] victim and always going down and
just trying to get somebody in trouble
and try and [ __ ] over there their
ability you know to earn a living
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] alright dear bill
would you rather have to live in an air
balloon for a month never having set
down or would you rather live in a
submarine never breathing the surface
for a whole month
both scare the [ __ ] out of me for a
whole month but I think I choose the
submarine seems more natural yeah
there's also a bathroom I wouldn't want
to have to [ __ ] on people and pyo
obviously wait till I was over a rural
area
yeah plus you'd be inside you'd have a
bed if you when you're in the submarine
you have a blanket you know you get to
be down there with all the fellas hey no
man I mean I think it would be cool to
[ __ ] look out the window and see all
the [ __ ] the sea life and all that
[ __ ] I would go [ __ ] nuts down there
but I don't know [ __ ] up there in an
air balloon gets cold or hot you're
really dealing with the [ __ ] elements
when you up there it starts [ __ ]
raining
[Music]
yeah I don't know I would be I would get
over that really quickly but I think
being in a sub
you know you down there you could flake
cards you could [ __ ] break each
other's balls or whatever I don't know
yeah I definitely would think I'd much
rather do a sub and if I had to die
either way I'd rather die in a sub I'd
rather have it just [ __ ] you know if
you're gonna die in a self that's gonna
be quick you know it's just over right
yeah I don't yeah I don't know sometimes
maybe it might not be quick they close
that door yeah those are two terrifying
things I got to go with you gotta go
with you on that Alright dilemma Billy
Boy if you had to choose which holiday
to get cancelled and never celebrate
again would you choose Valentine's Day a
Presidents Day who deserves more
recognition your girl for doing what you
do all year without a holiday that's
hilarious yeah we don't get a holiday no
maybe I read that wrong or presidents
who may or may not be horrible people
who hurt the country I cancel Presidents
Day because I'd rather keep the one that
involved chocolate being around it's a
good reason for it oh if I had to get
rid of one I don't think anybody really
celebrates Presidents Day I don't really
consider it a day off its kind of like
Flag Day you know what I mean
or buttermilk pancakes day isn't there
one of those [ __ ] days - geez do you
want me to cancel a holiday
I wouldn't cancel Valentine's Day just
cuz women like it so much believe it or
not I am a [ __ ] but I'm not that [ __ ]
bad so I'd keep that one yeah you know
what [ __ ] Presidents Day all those guys
have bought and sold anyways you've seen
it with Hillary Clinton and Bernie
Sanders you've seen how the Democrats
are just gonna pick her because she's
gonna play ball they're all tied into
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] I don't know
what you want to call it that she that
Bernie Sanders is too [ __ ] radical
he's gonna switch it up too much and
then they're not gonna work with them
even if Bernie Sanders gets [ __ ]
elected they're not gonna work with them
they're gonna show their [ __ ] true
colors they're a bunch of the
a bunch of they're all bought and paid
for they how the [ __ ] did that Clinton's
got three million dollars to throw their
kid a wedding you know what I mean me a
[ __ ] break because you went out you
gave speeches to all the people that
[ __ ] financed your campaign and then
you hooked him up and look the other
[ __ ] way I swear to God I swear to God
do you wonder how the [ __ ]
pharmaceutical companies and the people
who [ __ ] up the food supply are able
to do it and there's nothing there's
nothing behind it's cuz they [ __ ]
paid everybody off I swear to God all
right I'm on my stomach my eyes this is
why I always vote for that third party
guy and everybody goes oh you're
throwing away your [ __ ] vote I was
thrown away my [ __ ] vote voting for
someone who's a decent [ __ ] human
being I swear to god people they don't
want to try to do what's right they just
want to win they want to be like oh my
god one stump again see that every time
I sit there and I trash people for
[ __ ] given their public opinion then
look at me look at me I do the exact
same thing I am what's known as a
hypocrite a hypocrite
alright that's the the podcast for this
week I want to thank everybody that came
out Cheyenne Wyoming I know it was last
second but I had a great time at a great
time in your your State Capitol I was
just a really really cool [ __ ] town
and I had a great time in the Cadillac
Ranch there that sounds I swear to God
like the [ __ ] bunny ranch it sounds
like a [ __ ] whorehouse but it wasn't
it was cool talking to the people there
and thank you to everybody you know they
bought me a beer and a shot and all that
[ __ ] thank you everybody in Denver by
the way which was just a [ __ ] insane
show that was another special one just
because I've done so many [ __ ] gigs
in Colorado in the middle of nowhere I
always bring up a rapaho Community
College I'll never forget that nooner
where they had me standing in an area
where three hallways met right before
class ended that was a [ __ ] nightmare
next to a popcorn machine and five
people scattered out about 40 chairs
empty chairs anyways that's the podcast
for this week I'm gonna try to watch
some Celtics and get caught up on the
Bruins games
and keep drinking my juice alright go
[ __ ] yourselves I'll talk to you later
on this week